hey guys so today we're gonna talk about
keto on steroids okay extreme weight
loss this is not for everyone it's for
those people that need to lose some
quick weight and some people that want
an unfair advantage and one that just
dive in and do whatever it takes to lose
weight healthily and fast okay so
typically when you do keto you have 5%
carbohydrates 20% protein and these are
calories total calories and 75% fat okay
so that's typically what you would do
what I'm gonna recommend is slightly
different we're gonna give you five
packs or strategies okay starting with
number one normally you would do 20 to
50 grams of carbs to do the 5 percent
right we're gonna bring the carbs down
to zero okay so yes this is extreme it's
not for everyone
but think about it the amount of
carbohydrates determine how deep into
ketosis you're going to go okay so we
want to go in there hardcore so if we go
zero carbs you will go into keto very
very fast now the thing with protein we
don't want to go too little we don't
want to go too much if we go too little
you may start losing muscle mass we
don't want that and might feel weak
because you need protein to replace body
tissue we go too much it's gonna bog
down your liver and kidney and also it
can potentially spike insulin we don't
want to do that the sweet spot is
between three and six ounces okay now
this really depends on several factors
how young you are how big you are how
slow the metabolism is there's a lot of
different factors for me I'm 180 pounds
I need about 55 grams of protein per day
and that's pretty much what I consume on
a daily basis I'm not gonna get into
calories at this point but I just want
to kind of give you a reference if
you're smaller than me you know have a
little less if you're bigger than me
have a little bit more okay so now the
strategy with protein is we don't want
to go lean we don't want to go low-fat
protein we want to get our fat in
protein as one so you want to start
consuming food that combines your fat
and protein and naturally well we
definitely do not want to go lean
because the leaner the protein the
higher the insolence
like there's a lot of information
related to something called an insulin
index okay I'm gonna put a link down
below on the video if you want more
information on the insulin index that
goes beyond just the glycemic index very
interesting some protein types that we
don't want is chicken Dairy Dairy tends
to be a problem with a lot of people
allergies and trying to find the quality
is an issue so I'm just gonna recommend
avoiding dairy at this point turkey we
that's very lean as well we don't want
it in Turkey we don't want to do turkey
bacon lean steak you can get a fatty
steak but don't do a lean steak we don't
want to go lean fish we want to do a
fatty fish peanuts are a low quality
protein I don't recommend it what we
want to focus on our fatty fish like
salmon sardines both of these are very
high in omega-3 fatty acids and high in
DHA very very important there's other
types of fish and seafood that you can
consume but these two are my go-to pork
now a lot of people don't like pork
that's totally fine personally I have a
high quality pork from the farmers
market pork sausage I love it it's very
fatty it's a very good thing to do in
Quito plus it has a lot of B vitamins
and it's if you are against pork because
it's unhealthy and you're eating chicken
then you need to reevaluate that because
chicken by the way is a very unhealthy
birds okay unless you do organic from
the farmers market you're going to get
something very low-quality
so I really like pork because it it
seems to digest well in my body and it
actually has a good amount of fat
hamburger fatty hamburger very very good
on a keto because we want the fat and
the protein when you're at the grocery
store don't get the leanest hamburger
okay it's like it's actually quite
disgusting it's hard to eat it there's
no flavor as well eggs very good
pasture-raised
organic now you can also do bacon as
well okay bacon believe it or not if you
fry it and take the grease out it's not
as fat as you might think okay but it's
fine because it kind of has a one-to-one
ratio
50% fat and 50% protein most of these
are a one-to-one ratio maybe a little
bit fat here okay so that's what you
want to do with the
team now as far as the fat goes you
don't again want to add extra fat like
you don't want to add MCT oil or a keto
bomb or Extra Butter to this program why
because we're doing extreme weight loss
and I'll explain why in a second the
types of fats that you can add in
addition to these would be avocados
because that will cover a lot of
nutrition and very very healthy fat
olives are good as well okay pecans are
really good has some protein and fat
almonds not as good as pecans but still
really good ok it's like a 1.5 ratio of
fat to protein I think pecans are like 2
to 1 or even 3 to 1 if I'm not mistaken
so the key is to make sure that the fat
naturally comes with the protein ok
together so it's not separate so now
there's a sweet spot for the amount of
fat that you consume per day and it just
happens to be for an average person ok
it could be a little bit more or less 75
grams ok when you consume and what your
body tends to burn more of the dietary
fat when you consume less than 75 grams
typically on average I'm being very
general your body will start to consume
its own fat what we want to do is get
your body to burn its own fat we don't
want to do unlimited fat where your body
is just turning the diet fat into
ketones and you definitely don't want to
do the exogenous ketones where you're
taking this supplement because we don't
want to have you run on that we want you
to run on your own fat this would be a
new concept for some people ok so that's
what would that look like
okay well 67 grams of fat here's an
example 4 strips of bacon
that's 13 grams 2 eggs 10 grams of fat 4
ounces of steak 24 grams ok a fat one
ounce of pecans 20 grams of fat so 67
grams of fat would be a perfect amount
of fat to help you get in the factory
now we don't want to start going extreme
low fat we don't want to go low fat so
we don't want to go below like 50 grams
of fat ok 50 to 75 I think is a really
good number because we
these fats for a lot of different
reasons it's gonna help you get into
ketosis it's going to support the brain
it's going to give you that type of
vitamins omega-3 essential fatty acids
and a lot of other things that's what we
do with the fat that's what we do with
the protein leafy greens okay why
because two things number one we need
our potassium magnesium nutrients
vitamins that type of thing which is
very very important and we need about
seven cups of vegetables minimally okay
don't have less than seven cups the
other thing that we need in addition to
vitamins and minerals is the fiber from
the vegetables and again I'm not
counting this as carbs because it's so
much fiber we're not doing a high
glycemic carbohydrate we're doing a
extremely nutrient dense fiber which is
not very sweet okay so leafy greens are
not very sweet the fiber is going to
specifically feed the microbes in our
digestive system which then will turn
into a very healthy fat called butyric
acid it's a fatty acid and that acid
will basically help insulin resistance
and even lower insulin it's really good
for blood sugars so this is going to
actually help us lose weight the
potassium in the leafy greens will also
help you lose weight because it lowers
incident resistance the goal is to keep
insulin as low as possible so this is
what we're taking consideration as we're
going through this zero carbs the fiber
exact amount of protein more fat which
is neutral with insulin fat is the one
of the only things that does not trigger
insulin now let's get to intermittent
fasting so if you've never done this
before I recommend you go right to two
meals a day I'll put a video down below
on in a minute fasting so you can just
quickly get updated on how to do that
but you want to go into 2 minutes a day
if you're already at 2 meals a day
you're gonna go to one meal a day ok so
the key is do not eat unless you are
hungry ok that's really I find a lot of
people are eating when they're not
hungry the way that you know that it's
working is that your hunger goes away
that means your body is eating your own
fat so let your body tell you when to
eat okay so we're gonna go for a period
of time and Wow I'm not hungry good ride
the way to ride the wave all of a sudden
I'm hungry at six o'clock and the
evening good that's your your first meal
it's totally okay to eat at different
times during the day okay now what's
gonna happen if you're new to this and
you're not gradually going into this and
I suggest maybe you want to go into it
gradually but if you don't and you just
go to one meal a day and do what I'm
saying it'll probably take three days to
get you fully into adaptation and you
might go through some fatigue and things
like that but it's a fast way to jump in
and get the results and if you're okay
with that go for it
there's some key things you want to know
sea salt it's very important to consume
sea salt on your meals per day you need
about a teaspoon of sea salt every
single day not a heaping teaspoon but a
level teaspoon okay very important it
wouldn't hurt to consume some
electrolytes as well get one with high
amounts of potassium okay the other
thing that I find that will help you and
this helps a lot of people is that when
you have a hard time consuming salad
because you're not easy used to
consuming that much consume your salad
wait for an hour and then consume the
rest of the food okay we'll consider
that as one meal just spread out for
maybe two hours okay that's not going to
be a problem because you're not going to
really spike instant too much from
eating that salad so you can come spread
it out let your digestive system deal
with the salad and then add the protein
in fat that way you'll have less
bloating okay now on the salad you can
put apple cider vinegar little C so if
you want the saw mcvinnie Guerette get
the kind that is not too sweet so you
want to avoid those and get the ones
that are a bit bitter and less sweet
okay guys there you have it this is keto
on steroids extreme weight loss go ahead
and try this and put your comments down
below
hey guys so there's a whole bunch of
people that really need this information
so press the share button and let's get
it way out there